Some of you might
want to present
what happens over time
with your photographs.
Other than creating a video,
it's usually quite compelling
when watching a dynamic
phenomena that's true.
And if you think about
it, all of science
is ultimately dynamic, right?
Things change over time.
We generally assume one
has to watch a moving image
to see that change.
So here, for example,
you are seeing
something called the
Belousov-Zhabotinsky reaction.
It's a complicated
oscillating reaction
that we're observing
within a Petri dish.
But it's not a video, in
the sense that it wasn't
taken with a video camera.
You're seeing a series of
still images that I made
and I was privileged
to make in professor
Zhabotinsky's lab at Brandeis.
I took the images
11 seconds apart
over a period of five minutes.
By the way, I made
the images in film,
which became slide formats,
as you might remember--
or then again, maybe you don't!
And you're seeing digital scans
of those individual frames.
We're seeing the
spiral waves forming.
A color indicator allows
us to see the reaction.
So what we're really seeing
is a series of still images,
one right after the other.
That is in fact what a
moving image is, isn't it?
So that looks
pretty interesting.
But in my opinion,
just as interesting,
is seeing the individual
images lined up in a grid,
so that we can compare
one image to the other,
and note two changes that occur.
I am convinced there is a place
for this kind of presentation.
Here's another example.
You're looking at
a one centimeter
across circular
"sandwich", let's call it,
of two pieces of glass.
The glass contains, within this
"sandwich", material called
block copolymers in a solvent.
And over time, the solvent
evaporates around the edges
so that over time the
block copolymers self
assemble in different
orientations.
And that change is
visually translated
into changes in color.
And so again, we're
seeing a series of stills,
one right after the other,
viewing it as a moving image.
But here too, looking
at each side by side
can clarify exactly
what is going on.
I just want you to
think a little bit
about seeing a series of stills
instead of only an animation.
By the way, here is that
still image in the journal.
Let's talk a little
bit about showing scale
in your presentations.
My purpose here is to nudge you
to think a little differently
from perpetuating the standard
approach to showing scale
within an image.
Instead of for example showing
that overused coin side by side
with your device, how about
making the composition ever so
slightly more interesting.
You could also think
about showing your device
on top of something other
than a coin, for example,
something more recognizable and
more interesting in structure.
In this case, I
use a compact disk,
which might not be familiar
from years to come,
but I'm trying in here anyway.
I hope you still
know what it is!
And in the caption we
can get more information
about the size of the
device or the material.
And here we're seeing
an image of a structure,
giving the reader both a
sense of scale and property.
The presence of the
coins suggests the scale
of the small objects,
but we're also
seeing that the structure itself
can collapse and then bounce
back, which is in fact
the important part of what
this is about.
In this image, which we'll
see again in week six,
you're seeing a
syringe needle, which
I used to place some colored
water onto a surface.
It's a suggestion of the scale
of the square drops of water.
It isn't quantitative.
But just a hint of
a size, if you know
the size of the syringe needle.
And another way you might
present an idea of scale
is to show something from
various points of view
as we zoom into the material.
So here is that old computer
memory core we saw before.
Something I'll bet most of you
haven't seen before this class.
And in the next image, I made
the picture with a 105 lens
getting closer to the material.
And again, here I'm coming
even closer with another tool,
something called a
stereo microscope.
Once again, even getting closer
with a compound microscope.
And finally, I made an image
with a scanning electron
microscope, which I've colored.
So yes, it's true.
I'm not exactly showing you
the exact size of the material,
but I'm taking you sort of
through a sense of scale
and maybe sort of
telling a scale story.
The same with this
morpho butterfly wing.
As we zoom into this
structure, first
taken with a camera and lens.
Then getting closer
to the material,
looking with a colored
scanning electron micrograph,
we see more detail.
And even getting more
enlarged, seeing it
with another scanning electron
micrograph, which I colored.
Now it appears blue
initially, but there's
no blue dye present.
The color is due to the
structure of the wing, which
is what we're seeing.
And it's an interesting story,
which I suggest you look into.
Here's another idea.
Instead of always
placing a scale bar
either in the lower right hand
corner or the lower left hand
corner, how about if we place
the scale bar within the image
in a more designed approach.
You just did see
an example of this.
And here's another example.
I've placed and labeled the
scale bar within the image.
The full design of the
image works better.
The information is there,
but doesn't compromise
the aesthetics of the image.
The scale bar works with it.
And the same with this image,
which you've also seen before.
The bar doesn't always
have to be on the bottom
right or left, unless of course
the journal insists on that.
There is no reason why it has
to be placed in that format.
That's one of those perpetuated
rules that, in my opinion,
have no logic to it.
For our book On The
Surface of Things,
we wanted to suggest a
comparative sense of scale
when looking at all of
the images in the book.
We used the head of a pin,
which measures about between one
to two millimeters,
as a reference point.
Next to each image,
you see a blue outline
of a pinhead made relative
to the size of what's
in the photograph.
So for example, looking at
this image of ferrofluid,
the pinhead appears
around this size.
Note the blue circle.
But when we have to zoom way
down to the nano scale level
in order to see the indentations
of this compact disk,
the pinhead circle almost
becomes a straight line.
We hardly see the curvature.
Because the indented
areas are so small,
we cannot use photons
to image that surface.
We have to use electrons with
a scanning electron microscope.
So just imagine traveling
down to that nano scale.
Well the pin head enlarges
as you pass it by.
I think it worked quite
well for the book.
I hope you do.